If everyone you loved was suddenly getting killed
by horrifying aliens, what would you do?
They can shapeshift into anyone you know,
and now nobody can be trusted.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do
and how to be too. The aliens in parasite.
This kid has no idea that he's supposed to die.
Shinichi here goes to sleep after a hard day
and puts on his headphones
when suddenly this insane alien sneaks into his room.
But Shinichi wakes up in shock to this terrifying creature
as it tries to burrow into his arm
and make its way to his brain.
Thinking fast,
this kid ties his arm up until it turns to red
because of his screams for help,
his parents come running in to see what's going on.
But just like that, the hole in his arm disappears
as if it were a horrifying dream.
The next day, he goes through his usual routine
but realizes that he feels different.
He's about to cross the street when suddenly
a car honks its horn at him and he takes a few steps back.
He then looks back at the road and sees a little girl
running into traffic, chasing after a ball
in a matter of seconds.
This tiny little girl is about to have her blood
paint the sidewalk without realizing it
she needs his body moves on its own
and jumps out in front of the car
to protect the girl and blocks it with his hand
completely destroying the car.
But he's totally fine.
He looks at his hand in shock and sees a horrifying eyes
staring right back at him.
And then it disappears. Shinichi
then runs home, desperate to find some answers.
He takes out a knife
and gets ready to cut off his own hand in horror.
He sees his hand transform into an alien,
and it SPEAKS! okay.
I no longer have full control over my own hand.
And now something else is inside and controlling it.
And right now I'm suddenly starting to wonder,
am I hallucinating an alien that's coming out of my hand?
Because this sounds something exactly like a science fiction
novel, and I would rather believe I'm infected
with a specific kind of virus that can cause
a visual hallucinations instead of an actual alien.
Now, living inside of my own hand.
We live in Japan
and there just so happens to be a virus in rural areas
of Southeast Asia and the Far East, known
as the Japanese encephalitis virus.
And this virus does in fact cause hallucinations.
And while symptoms could appear, this virus can cause
mild to no symptoms in certain people in the very beginning.
Which could explain why I'm now starting to trip balls
with seemingly no reason whatsoever.
Also, every two and three people who catch this
virus on average go on to develop more serious symptoms.
And this could explain why I'm suddenly feeling fine
and now hallucinating an alien living in my hand.
In order to preserve my sanity,
I would ride this hallucination, train and see what the hell
this alien has to say.
Because in the best case, my hallucinate version
is full of shit and I can go to the hospital
and endure several months of painful recovery.
And worst case, my hallucination isn't a hallucination
and the doctors won't know what to do
and contact the government
and now have me shipped off to Japan's version of Area 51.
Shinichi is horrified as hell and this alien tells him
that it has taken over his arm forever.
But then it suddenly goes to sleep,
leaving Shinichi more clueless and terrified than before.
He spends the whole night trying to find out
anything that he can on this alien when morning
comes, he wakes up to see his hand
attached to a crazy creature reading.
Shinichi thinks he's in a nightmare, but this alien explains
to him that the horrors have only just begun.
It says it doesn't know where it came from,
only that it had to take over his brain,
but apparently got stuck in his arm instead and failed.
It warns this kid
that if he tries to tell anyone about this situation,
the government will probably capture him
for horrifying experiments.
Did I not just say that? Dang, I'm good.
This alien mentions to Shinichi
that since they're now stuck with each other,
they should work together for now, In the morning.
Shinichi, his family, hears on the news
about more horrifying murders that have recently started
popping up in Japan.
Later, while out on a walk, Shinichi alien friend senses
another alien creature nearby.
Shinichi freaks out, but the alien tells him that
finding answers to what's going on will help both of them.
They confront the alien and find out that it's inside
a dog's body and that this creature is hungry.
Shinichi Alien tells him to get to cover
and the 2 prepare for Shinichi first battle.
But to their surprise, it ends quickly with Shinichi alien
killing this one by taking out its heart.
The kid's alien tells him that they won this time
because the hostile alien wasn't able to merge properly
with its host, giving Shinichi a valuable edge in combat
and that this is something he should remember for later.
O. K.
While this may seem insane
that we have an alien residing inside of our hand
and somehow our body is not rejecting it on earth.
There is a little devil known as the Spiral Metra tapeworm
that can do the same thing
that this alien is doing living inside the body of a human
without causing bodily complications.
The spiral metal tapeworm can live inside of the brain
of a human for up to 20 years without causing any problems.
And this actually happened to a dude in China.
In a way, Shinichi should be grateful
that his body isn't rejecting it,
and this alien isn't able to take over his body
or spread a little larva inside of him.
Which, by the way, the tapeworm known as the tenia
Solium, can do this tiny little honey.
Bunches of oats can burrow itself inside of the body and can
cause infection from the larva that this parasite has.
Imagine this little darling bringing little larva babies
into the world at the expense of your body,
causing organ damage in the lungs, brain, liver,
and a bunch of other nasty crap.
At the moment, we know that the alien cannot fully
take over Shinichi's body, which means we should put aside
the thought of trying to remove it
and instead focus on working with him.
Because from what we saw of how the two interacted
during that fight with the dog alien, they got lucky.
There are other ones out there like them
that aren't going to be so easy.
They need to learn to work together and fast.
Shinichi realizes that he'll die if he doesn't team up
with this alien and begins to call it Migi
and then finds out that the gruesome murders happening
all over Japan have started to happen all over the world.
And this girl says that the police here
are trying to keep things quiet,
but videos of these murders have leaked onto the Internet.
According to Migi, the aliens feed on whatever species
they inhabit.
The alien invades a dog, it now eats dogs.
The alien invades a human. It eats humans.
Shinichi realizes that these murders mean that
the horrifying alien invasion has already begun worldwide.
After school, Shinichi takes a walk when suddenly
MIgi senses another alien headed straight for them.
And this time, this alien is a stone cold killer.
Migi demands that Shinichi gets the hell out of there,
but instead this kid walks toward the killer.
Migi calls Shinichi a crazy bastard.
But this kid is determined to stop this alien invasion
all by himself.
And that's when they come face to face with this alien.
And they prepare for battle.
But this blond baddie then reveals something terrifying
and says that Migi can in fact
invade his body instead, and that all he has to do
is to kill Shinichi before he goes.
This guy cuts off his arm and leaves it wide open for Migi.
He demands that Shinichi dies
and raises his tentacle to kill him,
when suddenly Migi blocks it and slices him to pieces.
Shocking, Blondie and Shinichi both.
Migi tells Shinichi that it simply didn't
trust this alien and decided
not to join him inside of that body and tell Shinichi
to cool it on the bromance.
The next day, Shinichi celebrates his victory
by living his life ordinary, and his parents
tell him that they're leaving for a few days on a hubba
hubba type of a trip, and Shinichi leaves for school.
But later, Migi pops up again with more bad news
and tells Shinichi that it senses another alien nearby.
Shinichi is hair
stand on end as him and Satomi head into class.
Nearby in the hall, MIgi tells Shinichi to stand guard
as the alien nearby is looking for them
and they realize that the alien close by is
in fact their new substitute math teacher, Ryoko.
Okay, this is some serious Texas chicken bullshit,
but there's something up with this scenario
that makes me think that we're not as doomed
as Shinichi thinks he is.
Now, thanks to Migi,
we know that these things are officially a race of aliens
that have floated down to earth from unknown origins.
Just like little dandelion seeds floating in the wind.
And they act similar to the parasite tapeworm tenia solium.
And those things burrow themselves inside of the body
and try to take over the central nervous system.
But these aliens, once they take over a human host,
are instinctively driven to hunt and kill humans,
and they seem to act similar to a virus,
because this thing, at the end of the day, seems to be
nothing more than a brainless,
non-living freeloader who will kill us at any chance it gets
unless it seriously wants something from us
and here is where I think we still hold all of the cards.
This alien has infiltrated our school to the point
of being an employed teacher, being this deep undercover
within the human population is not the norm.
It means that this alien has an agenda.
Otherwise, why else would it go through all of this trouble
when it could just attack everyone right here and now?
This means that this alien is different.
It wants something until it gets
what it wants. It's not going to attack us.
Otherwise it would have done so already for the time being.
As long as we're surrounded by dozens of students
and faculty members, this alien isn't going to touch us,
even if it desperately wants to.
And we should use this opportunity to confront this thing
right after the assembly while we're still surrounded
by witnesses, Shinichi spends the day sweating buckets,
wondering what this horrifying
alien Ryoko is up to, but later runs into her at this café
and is offered a peace treaty.
She introduces another alien friend to Shinichi and mentions
that she wants to maintain her cover
because she is pregnant.
This check has begun horrifyingly steamy experiments
with this dude trying to create half human,
half alien babies just like Shinichi,
and says that they both should not get in each other's way.
But this alien dude who looks dumb as bricks
says that the peace treaty is stupid
and he leaves and prepares to kill Shinichi very soon.
The next day in class, Shinichi studies when suddenly
both Ryoko and MIgi warn him that trouble is coming.
It's the dumbest Brick's dude
and he's coming to kill Shinichi.
But this time, this kid prepares to stand his ground
and sets up a mini shitty fortress
that doesn't look all that impressive.
But this cold hearted
killer is ruthless and surprises him through the window.
But media quickly tells Shinichi
that these aliens think humans are too scared to fight them,
so they never expect Shinichi to try and kill them.
Mika then sets up a plan giving this kid
a weapon and tries to keep the alien distracted.
As Shinichi cautiously tries to go for this monster's heart.
They work together in harmony
until Shinichi manages to stab this alien right in his soft
spots and blood spills everywhere.
And this alien walks off to die.
Later, as the school cleans up the mess.
Shinichi leaves the area and runs into Ryoko again.
She's pissed as hell.
She mentions that the school fired her for just
what happened and blames it on Shinichi.
She prepares to skin him alive,
but he begs her to listen to him for 1/2.
He mentions that Migi feeds off of his blood
and tells her that aliens can survive without killing humans
because of this.
But Ryoko thinks that it's simply natural selection
killing off humans.
But then she realizes something.
Shinichi is becoming more alien than human and thinks
MIgi will soon take over his entire body.
She goes away and leaves Shinichi behind and he wonders
if it's only a matter of time until his human side dies.
A few days later, Shinichi enjoys life without his parents
at home, when suddenly he gets a call from his dad.
He says in broken words to Shinichi that his mother is dead
and mentions that a horrifying monster did it
and the call suddenly ends.
Shinichi is frozen in shock, but MIgi shows up
and tells him something even more terrifying.
It says that the monster alien who killed
Shinichi will likely come for him next,
and that to prepare for the horrors
that are about to show up at their doorstep.
No, this is so not fair. This should be party time.
The parents are out of town
and it is now turned into a real Debbie Downer.
Here's what we know.
We know for certain that the enemy parasite is going to need
at least half a day's ride to get to us.
We know where our parents went.
The alien coming for us
is going to take a few hours minimum to reach us.
This means we have some time to prepare.
These alien parasite things, while hard to kill,
can be killed, as we saw with the dog parasite.
These aliens rely on the host's body's
capabilities to an extent just like dumb
as brick's guy from before puncturing their vital organs
or severing the head is enough to kill them,
which makes them arguably similar to humans.
Which means we just need a clear shot to kill.
It's noted that our daddy said a monster killed our mama,
not monsters, plural.
Which means we know for a fact
that we're up against one alien bastard.
And this alien bastard
simply needs to have a knife plunged into his soft spots.
Or we can go a little extra with our methods
because we don't know anything about this alien or its host.
So I'd say let's up
the ante and go on a little more flammable measure.
If I was Shinichi, I would go to the nearest gas station
and fill up some containers full of gasoline.
Next, I would do the Google and buy the biggest water gun
that the store has, preferably a super soaker of some sort,
and fill it with gasoline.
From there, I would buy some thin glass bottles, motor oil
and some leather gloves and use the fabric shirts
in my house to make some Molotov cocktails.
Next, when back home,
if I was Shinichi, I would turn on the gas
stove and begin hitting up a bunch of knives
from the kitchen for however long we've got left.
The parasite is all about self-preservation
and keeping itself alive, which means its system will react
to any sort of heat being placed on its skin in a negative
way, causing it to overreact and make mistakes.
This ill will freak out at the induction of a heated weapon.
Plus, having its entire body set on fire,
it will be too preoccupied to focus on us.
We'll get a warning from Migi once it's near.
While Migi keeps it busy,
we will soak the bastard in gasoline at a distance.
First with our water gun, then we'll use our Molotov
cocktails to set this guy on fire.
Once we find an opening,
we'll stab this thing in the heart with our red hot knife.
Migi is highly intelligent
and will easily be able to help us out in setting this up
and coordinating the plants to take this alien bastard down.
Shinichi needs to get off of his ass and start preparing.
The next day arrives more sinister than before.
Shinichi wakes up to Migi,
telling him that the alien killer is right outside.
He's shocked and grabs
a knife to prepare for combat, waiting in the shadows
until he comes face to face with the killer.
It's his mom
Realizing that the alien has taken over his mother.
Shinichi panics and stops Migi from attacking
just as he gets stabbed through the heart,
collapsing on the floor and sees the cold face of his mother
reacting with no emotion.
She leaves the two to die right there as Migi thinks fast
and it does something insane.
It merges with Shinichi, his heart forcing this little
what's his heart to keep beating.
Shinichi miraculously begins healing
as MIgi slowly brings him back from the dead days past,
when Shinichi finally wakes up
and feels almost better than human, he suddenly gets a call
from a faraway hospital where his dad is resting
and prepares to go to see him as soon as possible.
He opens the door and waves goodbye to Satomi.
And this kid prepares
to go to fight his demons in the flesh.
Meanwhile, Shinichi is dead
at the hospital, is horrified to learn
that his wife is not dead and has been spotted around town.
The dad said he saw Shinichi, his mother,
get brutally murdered right in front of him,
but the doctors think he's simply gone insane.
Shinichi finally arrives at the dead, all pumped up on meds,
tells him to chill out because everything is fine.
But Shinichi knows everything is not fine
and shit's about to hit the fan.
He decides to stay in town for a few days
to watch over his dad.
But that night, Omega reveals something horrifying.
It tells Shinichi
that because MIgi merged his entire body with then Shinichi
that this transformation has come at a terrifying cost.
Migi has begun to pass out every day for 4 hours
and will now not be able to sense any bad guys.
They try and attacks and Ichi or his dad during this time.
Okay, this could be a serious problem.
Shinichi. Physiology has been altered at the cost of Migi.
The extreme amount of effort needed from Migi to save him
now forces Migi to need a little power nap every day.
This sucks.
Now I got to worry about what I'm going to do
when Migi goes to sleep.
What we have to figure out as soon as possible is.
Is that.
Does it matter when Migi goes to sleep, or does he really
only need a nap whenever he gets completely tapped out?
Energy wise, how much does it take out of him to augment
and eat his body whenever he fights other aliens?
How quickly can we get Migi tired?
These are the things that we need to know.
We got to figure out how to get as much done as possible
when Migi is awake.
Because now we have to come up with alternatives
on how we protect our daddy.
If Migi's nap time is dependent on its energy usage,
then I'm going to try to use him as little as possible
and find a spot where we can hide up in for a while
whenever Migi needs his nap.
We don't know when that alien scum
is going to attack our father.
This means until we get a work around on this thing,
will effectively be on edge.
24 seven and it sucks.
Now the most obvious period of time to strike
our dad would be during the hours of the night
when the hospital will be the most empty.
However, knowing the alien entering the hospital
during the hours of the day will be the best time to strike,
as this will allow it to enter and blend
in through bigger crowds without arising too much suspicion.
and taking the least obvious option to attack during
the day will be likely when it chooses to strike,
as this thing is one sneaky mother of a pearl.
Therefore, we got to figure out Migi's now times.
Right now Migi is my ace in the hole
and I need to be able to use him whenever a crisis arises.
The next day, Migi suddenly senses an enemy at the beach
nearby.
Shinichi rushes like hell and prepares
to take out his dad's attacker.
But all he finds is this guy the least alien hybrid ever.
And they realize that this guy is just like Shinichi,
a parasite human hybrid with a big mouth.
And I mean that literally big mouth here
works near the hospital that Shinichi, his dad, is in
and he happily offers to warn Shinichi
if any enemies show up near his pops while Migi is sleeping.
This guy is one lonely dude.
Later, Migi points out something interesting
and mentions that earlier on the way to the beach,
Shinichi ran and jumped like someone with superpowers.
But Migi tells him something even more insane.
Migi declares that its cells are now no longer
just within Shinichi.
His head, after restarting Shinichi, is wussy heart.
Migi sales have now spread all throughout this kid's body,
making Shinichi stronger, faster and less human.
Just then, he gets a call from Big Mouth
and he tells Shinichi that him and his alien friend
have spotted a horrifying parasite.
But Shinichi knows that these creatures
are smarter than anyone thinks.
And he tells Bigmouth to get out of there
before he gets his clumsy ass spotted.
But it's already too late.
Shinichi runs as fast as possible to find big mouth,
but Migi suddenly gives Shinichi
a sword before it passes out again, leaving him all alone
for the most terrifying fight of his life.
He suddenly hears Big Mouth's screams
nearby, falling over this cliff.
Shinichi shows up only to find his worst enemy,
instead his mother or what's left of her.
A mindless alien ready to kill, pissed off
Shinichi slices and dices.
This alien bastard, but at the last minute
he chokes, looking at his mother's loving eyes.
Because it's so nice, right?
This alien bastard then takes advantage of Shinichi
his weakness, and prepares to kill him right there.
But all of a sudden an injured bigmouth
comes back from the cliff and brutally kills
Shinichi, his mother's alien corpse once and for all.
Big Mouth then mentions that aliens think little of humans
and they repeat their fight pattern
since they think most humans won't test their skills.
This is their weakness.
The gang saves the day and his dad is all better.
Shinichi takes his family back to his hometown, but
this is only the beginning of his horrifying transformation.
Shinichi realizes
that he's now become even stronger and faster than before.
As if he's evolving. But something's not right.
Shinichi asks me for advice.
He's starting to feel less human and hasn't been able
to feel any emotion since he came back from the dead.
But MIgi thinks that he's just becoming a more
"efficient" human.
Okay, this is some serious
Baskin-Robbins 31 flavors type of bull crap.
Shinichi here has started to feel weird, and I wouldn't
put it past him to think that what's happening
to him is a direct result of Migi's
diddling with his body on a cellular level.
But here's something crazy to think about.
What Shinichi is experiencing in terms
of feeling like his personality has changed
could actually be rooted in real life science.
We don't know the exact method through
which MIgi saved Shinichi his life, but
we do know what he effectively did was an organ transplant
to some degree.
Migi basically transferred some of its cellular DNA
into Shinichi, his body healing
Shinichi using cells from its own alien body.
But here's where it actually gets kind of crazy,
because Shinichi could be feeling like his body is changing
due to a concept in science called body memory.
Body memory is the medical hypothesis not yet fully proven.
That suggests that not just the brain, but the body itself
is capable of strong memories on a cellular level.
Think about how crazy that sounds for a second.
Think about it, because the rundown of this whole thing
is that personality changes following organ transplants
have been reported by patients for nearly decades worldwide,
and these reports have varied from people claiming
that they've had changes in emotions, changes in identity,
and inheriting memories from their donors life.
Now, I know this sounds crazy,
and while this isn't considered 100% scientifically
validated or properly understood
or any type of scientific lens as of yet,
this could be one theory to help explain how and why
Shinichi is experiencing changes and his state of being.
And let's not forget Migi's genetic code is clearly
something that has not come from this planet.
Okay?
We don't know yet if what Migi has done to Shinichi
is going to end out, well, long term.
The next day at school,
Migi sent us another alien monster headed right for them.
But this one is different
and catches up to them during gym class.
He introduces himself as Shimada and mentions
that he only wants Shinichi to help.
This alien race has begun to look for ways
to coexist with humans without eating them.
Or so he says.
Migi doesn't trust this guy one bit and pulls Shinichi
away, mentioning they'll think about this guy's offer later.
The police send guys to check in on Shinichi
so that they tell him the truth, that more and more deaths
have started happening around Japan and the government knows
that horrifying aliens are a real threat.
The dad tells them what his alien attacker looks like
and the government prepares themselves for a threat
never seen before.
The dad fills Shinichi
in about what really happened to his mother.
Shinichi silently
listens, keeping his alien secret close to his chest.
But glasses go. Begins to suspect of this Shimada kid.
Over the next few days. And her gut tells her
that something is not right about this guy.
One day she notices
this dude get hit in the face with a baseball
and he horrifyingly fixes his skull in front of her eyes.
Shocked.
She follows Shimada into town
and sees him transform into another human.
This girl's mind cracks
and she prepares an acid trap the following day at school.
But Shimada senses her plan and transforms
into a horrifying flesh eating alien right in front of her
eyes and prepares to eat her right then in there.
But this chick throws the acid right in his face,
distracting him while she escapes through this window.
Outside the football team sees glasses girl fall
and she tells them what's really going on.
Shocked.
These kids run inside the school to find this alien, but
unfortunately for them, they all get brutally sliced apart.
Horrifying. Everybody nearby, people start freaking out.
And this alert Shinichi nearby.
He then decides to play hero and goes to kill Shimada
before he murders anyone else.
The police reach the school,
but they're no match for Shimada.
Horrifying powers.
Migi then offers a smart plan to Shinichi,
and he runs up into the building next door
and he waits for an exhausted Shimada to walk out,
just as this alien freak busts
open the rooftop door and Shinichi puts
one stone cold hole right in his chest, killing him dead.
Okay, this is some little house on the prairie type bullcrap
due to his parasite's core physical preservation mode.
His cells, as a result of whatever glasses girl did to him,
means that Shimada
body had begun to freak out,
trying to protect him from internal damage.
This freak out of his cells
means that she might have lost control over his parasite
cells, and this was likely
the only reason that Shinichi was able to kill him
as his senses and body's
motor control were a little distracted.
This is also why Shimada walks out onto the rooftop,
still in alien mode.
Again, this shows whatever glasses girl did to him
truly made him lose control of his alien cells
as he was unable to disguise himself
to turn back into a human or well look like one.
Now, while what Shinichi did was smart in the short term.
Realistically, Japan's finest would have probably been able
to trace that rock throne
back to the direction of the building
that Shinichi was standing on when he threw it,
and most likely could have caught him
while going up that building through any nearby CCTV footage
and or caught him directly in the act of turning his arm
into an alien arm.
This move was way too
risky and could have exposed his secret.
He should have opted to blend in within the crowd.
Instead, it's noted that at the battle
with blond dude from earlier, we won that battle
as that alien didn't expect us a human to fight back
and actually attack it.
This is one of the other weaknesses that these aliens face.
They suffer from delusions of grandeur.
They suffer from the fact
that they think they are more powerful than they really are.
And because of this, no human will dare attack them.
And that is what we can use against them.
Going under the radar and using these aliens
confidence against them would have been the smarter move.
Shinichi should have opted to confront the alien nearby.
Within the school
itself, Migi was able to detect his location
and could have retraced the bloodshed
leading into the initial room the glasses girl was in, and
from there we could have seen exactly what caused Shimada
to freak out all of a sudden within that room,
because all the screams and killing
came from the top floor of the school,
which means Shimada was calm and in human form
leading up to that room.
And that means something caused him to lose it
instantaneously.
Going to the top floor room and seeing the acid bottle,
the glasses go left and or droplets
of a dripping on the floor means that Shinichi
could have known that from that Shimada was badly injured.
Migi would have known this because Migi's body
and Shimada's alien body have the same physiology.
And we could have used this knowledge to confront Shimada
as he tried to make his way to the roof and killed him
right there, using some sort of sharp object
that we find along the way.
While the key component of this plan is simple
killing Shimada at close range with an improvised
edged weapon, it still would have allowed us
to use the excuse that we ran into him
and killed out of result of self-defense.
At least this is what we could have told the police.
This would not have given away
our alien secret to the police
once they got their forensic team to examine Shimada body.
And we could have turned all the attention that would have
been on us into simply a kid who got lucky and lived.
We ran into this alien by accident,
and we got lucky by killing it.
In order to save our lives.
This would have been the better move to cover our tracks
into killing Shimada and would have been the best
move in order to keep our alien secret safe.
The government is horrified
and tries their best to keep Shimada alien BS a secret.
The next day they discussed the ongoing alien invasion
and what terrors they must plan for.
But this doctor has a genius idea.
He tells these guys that the public should know
about these creatures,
and he's found a clever way to tell humans and aliens apart.
If you pull out a strand of parasites,
hair, eyebrow eyelashes, that single strand of hair
will melt within a few seconds,
unlike a piece of hair from a human.
This is how they'll be able to tell
who is an alien and who is a human.
But these politicians don't realize that these horrifying
flesh eating monsters have a terrifying plan of their own.
Meanwhile, Shinichi is walking in town when he stops dead
in his tracks and looks within this crowd.
He and MIgi realize that these six people
running for government office are all parasites.
And Migi tells Shinichi
that the end of the world is about to begin.
These parasites have begun to take over
the government of Japan, and it won't be long
before they take over this country and eventually the world.